I see you going into your man turtle
shell you're just afraid of being a real
man that shows his oh yeah emotions I'm
gonna buy a real big truck to him bigger
than I've ever had before I'm gonna get
a real small smart smart car that's
electric you guys are you guys are
talking you're the one who [ __ ] has
the truck you're the one who [ __ ]
gave away his Mini Cooper like what is
happening right now I'm giving away
feeding and opposites you sold that [ __ ]
dude that sold that [ __ ] smallest car
that I can't even fit into
[Music]
oh
[Music]
complete the sentence if you die in the
game
you you died in real life
what if that was about to happen in
reality what do you mean like this is a
game no in video What If Nvidia games
they created a VR headset that actually
kills you if you die in the game that's
crazy fun that's happening right the
fuss the point that's not fair you know
what if
um punishment you know that that uh
euthanasia thingy instead of doing that
long we do this and then we can all
watch us this is a Black Mirror episode
so do you guys know who Palmer lucky is
who's that he is a video game developer
and
um he he created Oculus or he helped to
create Oculus and he is creating a
version of oculus that is fitted with uh
explosive charges oh cool that will kill
you if you die in a game this is I have
the perfect utility for this it doesn't
make sense at all okay
so poetic justice Tom okay people that
create or cause like [ __ ] up crimes
like tortured people or whatever we slap
this on and we let them live that
and then they die
what game are they playing
this year's harvesting this is still in
in concept and testing phases right now
but the idea behind it so you you played
games before have you ever are you
familiar with what permadeath is yeah so
in a fire emblem is huge on permit death
there you go so like there's a game
called Diablo that's big on permanent
some for if you want to play a hardcore
mode this character's just gone ski no
progress you don't keep your items you
are permanently dead in the game yeah so
like taking this to a
the umpteenth degree is kind of what
Palmer lucky is up to here that's pretty
uh it's cool but it's it's you know what
I don't like it because dying is part of
the fun of playing games
and instead of I mean
I would understand it if you died
because if you had a headset that killed
you if you said the N word during the
Call of Duty Lobby
[Laughter]
fireworks on Fourth of July already
this just did 80 million deaths yeah
yeah you'd be like holy [ __ ] my [ __ ]
Grandma's dead but like I think that's
more helpful or just like have something
shock you in the nuts if you're being
racist on a game Lobby is it a is it
like a punishment thing
um he's saying I mean I I think it's
just a promotional thing it's like all
of them get shipped to Guantanamo you
know what I mean yeah oh yo how crazy
would that be is if you [ __ ] don't
die but when you take it off you're in
quantity I don't know how he'd ever sell
this thing for example like how you saw
something with explosive charges fitted
to it then just adrenaline Seekers right
someone who already wants to die like
euthanasia Styles but they're gonna have
it for fun right yeah who's playing in
the USA you can't it's cheaper just to
kill somebody without a headset
seriously
didn't Jack Kevorkian go to jail for
that yeah for assisted suicides yeah too
many of them free my boy Jack Doug why
can't you ethics we don't have real
Freedom Joe you don't even have freedom
over your own body that's sad I I still
only see this in maybe punishment I I
see the idea of like somebody who's like
on death row you know what I mean and
being uh whether it be
um ironic like Poetic Justice you know
what I mean it's whether it's like
making somebody play Flappy Birds so
they actually die yeah or something
similar to the crime that they committed
all right you want to kill people keep
killing people until you [ __ ] die
yourself I don't know you know be the
sickest [ __ ] turn of phrase for this
whole thing is if everybody was under
the impression that that's what's gonna
happen you're gonna die and instead
the first person he used it rather than
die they just got hit with like the
sickest Ayahuasca trip so they thought
they were dead and then they just come
to and they're like oh my God
I want to be a better person now the
profundity of Life yeah that's a good
opportunity I'd be sick right like they
don't and then the whole time the guy is
like ah that is what I meant by death
death of once yeah
and then the guy who bought it to kill
someone's all God damn it I want my
money back I think the guy who's
designing this is like no that's not
what I mean Ryan yeah what does happen
in the ego death I don't know
Ayahuasca your old your old self is uh
is killed and and you shed your past
self and then you become the new man you
are supposed to be but then you develop
another ego then how you should yeah
yeah but unless you want to be a simp
Eagles are healthy because they help you
stay alive you want self-preservation
isn't that why humans stay alive you
have to kill your first ego because it
innately has uh toxic masculinity so oh
I don't like toxic masculinity yeah I
don't like betas yeah well you know what
maybe you should [ __ ] be not afraid
to express your emotional side nah dude
I'm a [ __ ] true Alpha
look at the way he's dressed yeah I
guess it's a [ __ ] outfit dude soak it
in I see you going into your man turtle
shell you're just afraid of being a real
man that shows his oh yeah emotions I'm
gonna buy a real big truck to him bigger
than I've ever had before not oh yeah
how big dude I'm gonna get a real smart
smart car that's electric you guys are
you guys are talking you're the one who
[ __ ] have the truck you're the one
who [ __ ] gave away his Mini Cooper
like what is happening right now I'm
giving away competing in opposites you
sold that [ __ ] dude that sold that [ __ ]
to make more money bro give it to a
church smallest car that I can't even
fit into
I do think that it's a great argument I
do think that it's honestly [ __ ] cool
when guys were like yo I'm really Alpha
like I think that's [ __ ] sick I like
it when guys have to say that they're
Alpha right I love it what's up what's
the alpha guy to you and the last
Colleen next honestly just just like a
guy who's just like yo I'm [ __ ] Alpha
man it's really that that's the epitome
of an alpha when you're working in
comedy in in like uh stage when you were
doing like improv did you ever have a
guy that was like the he thought he was
the funniest [ __ ] guy out of all you
guys I think everyone did that in the
beginning everyone doesn't work in a
group they're just trying to be the star
that's just natural the Natural
Evolution of like improv group stuff
because they don't know how to play
together that's when I realized I wasn't
playing well together when when my
mentor pulled me aside he's like Yo dude
this way you suck he's like you're
killing me wait wait that's what he said
yeah yeah he Alpha do yeah it was
awesome actually it was one of the best
things I ever had told me what did he
actually say um he's like you want to
know why you're not funny and then he
and then he's like because yeah you're
not you know you're not funny yeah it
was great it was good it was really good
for me it was really really good for me
but it was it was one of those things
where I realized the value of the team
and like not being a me provider not
being there for you like supervising
people up and not just Oh you mean all
Steve they got right here much has
changed huh
right now everyone's excited everyone's
[ __ ] like there's a lot of Joy are
the reviews in though reviews already
it's hot show on time on TV is projected
to be a huge [ __ ] projected by the
way for this device what's the method of
how it kills you explosive devices like
C4s on your head like on your head let's
just stop straight up bomb three bombs
you just blow your brains out great
little charges to compress your skull
bones dude I don't understand I thought
it was gonna be like I thought it was
going to be like the uh No Country for
Old Men three cattle projects oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that should be no this is way
more unrealistic in my opinion you'll
never get to you'll never get to Market
with this there's no point in having to
be a bomb though because then it'll just
blow up the tech too you've been like I
don't know can't you not even sell it
until it's a proven concept so it
wouldn't have to have worked once for
you to say yeah people would have to
test it yeah and you'd have to actually
kill a dude or else you can't really say
that's what it does this is a horrible
business plan because you'll have no
return customers there's no return
customers no return all your customers
are dead that's what I'm saying like
except for the hooker ghost the hooker
ghost why would the hooker ghost benefit
from me
that's true it's true she absolutely
wouldn't she myself especially if she
uses this product those big dick dudes
are using it
that makes sense to me
it's the number one suicidal VR set for
big dick dudes
an infomercial that writes itself and
then these these hookers are like oh
[ __ ] no that's interesting and then they
can rest in peace
yeah there you go I feel like this idea
of the alpha dude has disappeared after
the 90s like there's no real oh it's
back brother it's back oh it's back now
that claim that they are they're nowhere
near a Rambo what are you talking about
they have way more views than we do yeah
dude Pete Davidson
I want to see an alpha dude and I gotta
be like you're not Jean-Claude Van Damme
who's Alpha to you bro who's like you're
you're Mount Rushmore of alpha Manzo
Hattori right here what about the liver
King dude look at this I guess so right
here come on baby that's [ __ ] Alpha
dude
he's so comfortable that he wears makeup
what about the rock he's pretty Alpha I
feel like the rock is the most Alpha guy
out there I know I think he's kind of a
[ __ ] though but you know what he's
missing so so the difference The Rock's
a [ __ ] what what what comes off as
Alpha to me is this person looks like he
could kill someone
there's that a little yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] I think men should be a
little
scary in that way where your other men
are afraid of you and I think that's
that's a little bit Alpha because then
it's like if you're just strong and
successful and you're clean it's like
yeah you're you're an epitome of a great
human being but you're not you're
talking about intimidation Factor huh I
don't think this he's capable of murder
all I'm saying is the rock can walk into
a Vin Diesel movie and Vin Diesel them
out okay that's a good that's really
good yeah Morongo walk into DC's
franchise and be like I'm Superman level
bring Superman to my life yeah but you
know Vin Diesel is still in the fast
movies and the rock is not because he
[ __ ] franchised his own fast and
Diesel outfit him out as a producer dude
oh good point ultimate Alpha so that's
modern Alpha right Alpha mine like I
said Vin Diesel is the most Alpha that's
why I was Sandy is politically Alpha so
who's the most Alpha Phil DeFranco Phil
DeFranco he's very yeah he has Killer
Instinct I can see it in his eyes he
sucks with fantasy football though too
much so not that outfit
[Laughter]
he loves his kids too much he loves his
kids yeah too bad true Alphas want to
eat their kids
better
protein
ancestral dude
there's got to be a little bit of like
primitive like elements to the guy I
think maybe that did disappear in the
90s I think so the more we say like
who's an alpha guy and the more we say
that phrase I feel like I don't know
what you're talking about it not being
so big so when you're in your in your
dojo there's no Alpha dude in the whole
Dojo
there's got to be a God that's what
dojos are right yeah we got some alpha
males this is the most beta
all they do is wiggle yeah they cuddle
at night yeah dude
what they do roll around on the ground
Jiu Jitsu is not very Alpha like the
idea of filthy Frank was the ultimate
Alpha
[Music]